well it was the day when all of Russia
voted and each region on its own level
throughout the day we have had reports
of multiple violations but thing is it
has been difficult to tell fact from
fiction for instance during the day we
heard a report at outrageous report that
a bus holding election observers was
shot up eventually the local police
debunked this claim debunked this report
saying it has nothing to do with reality
it simply did not happen and in total
the interior ministry received some 300
reports more than 300 reports of
violations and they have said that they
will be looking into those closely at
the same time the Election Committee
will be dealing with all the fakes
according to the head of the Election
Committee they will be putting together
they will be compiling all of the fake
reports of violations and well compiling
them together and revealing which
reports were fake
we need to obtain all the fakes and
publish them on our website for our
colleagues abroad as well as within this
country to cover all that's happening
more carefully also Russia's official
media watchdog has accused Google and
Facebook of running political ads on the
election day this is something in
violation of Russia's election law they
have not yet revealed what sort of
action they're going to take in
connection with this when it comes to
the results of the elections
well a decisive picture will be
available on Monday
you